- The problem is it's your
fucking life and it's gonna end
up one way or the other.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
- [Gary] It's
like just so gloomy.
I hate this gloomy shit.
Oh yeah, it's
starting to get windy.
I can see it now.
That's a good shot, DRock.
You should get it.
- [DRock] Of what?
I can't see.
- [Gary] Here I'll get it.
I'll get it, DRock.
The branches
fucking flying like crazy.
- [DRock] Blurry,
you got to turn that.
- [Gary] I did it,
I did it all by myself.
Oh the branches
slowed down a little bit.
(DRock laughs)
But these peeps are
running pretty good.
I think I can get used to this
with color commentary.
Nice umbrella.
(DRock and Gary laugh)
("Cookie Crumbles" by D Press)
- [DRock] Thank you.
- [Avi] You got it.
- Shit, did I do
that again? Mother fucker.
- [Avi] Did it break?
- [Gary] Yep.
Fuck, sorry about that.
Pick up another one.
It's windy in New York.
It's windy, yo.
'Sup?
- [Man] Gary.
- [Gary] How are
you guys? How you doin'?
How's it going?
- [Man] Gary, we're
just starting introductions.
- [Gary] Great.
- [Man] Saying hi.
We're all kind of
new with one another.
- [Gary] Very nice.
- [Man] By the way,
good morning.
- [Gary] Good to see you bro.
- [Woman] Thanks for housing us.
- [Gary] No problem.
Great to see you.
Good to see you.
Awesome, well thanks everybody.
Thanks for being here.
Let me know if
I could be of help.
Thanks.
- [Darshan] This
is pretty swanky.
- [Gary] It's pretty swanky.
- [Darshan] The view is great.
- [Gary] Sick, right?
- [Darshan] I really would like
to see it snow and feel like
I was in a snow globe.
(Gary laughs)
That's what I was hoping but
I don't think I'm
gonna get my wish.
- [Gary] You might get
wind that shatters the glass
and you bleed all over.
- [Darshan] Okay,
that sounds lovely.
- [DRock] That was
a little aggressive.
- [Gary] Was that a little?
- [DRock] Seemed
a little aggressive.
- [Gary] Sorry.
Hi.
- [Alissa] Hi, how are you?
- [Gary] How are you?
I'm Gary.
- [Alissa] Good, I'm Alissa.
- [Gary] Alissa, how are you?
- [DRock] Back at it, huh?
- What?
- [DRock] Back at it.
- Back at it.
- [Woman 2] What is something
you wanted to be when you were a
kid but you never did?
- [Alex] Tall.
(group laughter)
- Cool.
I'm focused on IG stories today
and getting everything set up
with some more IG posters.
Yeah, that's it.
- [Gary] The best flip.
- The best flip
this RC helicopter thing.
- Yeah.
- [Chris] It was like $3 on eBay
selling for like 30 so I'm just
waiting for that to flip.
- [Gary] Love it.
$30 like used?
- [Chris] Yeah.
- [Gary] Love it.
Making that money.
- DailyVee 137 and
making adjustments on the intro
to use the new Saba track.
- [Gary] Oh yeah, is that today?
- Yeah.
- I got orientation today
so I'm kind of doing that.
Get to know the
office and everybody.
- [Gary] Where you from?
- New Orleans. Yeah.
But born in New Orleans and
I moved to Houston and yeah.
- [Woman 2] I
guess more Instagram.
I don't have anything else.
Maybe I start some analyzing
like what's been effective.
- [Eliot] Do that.
- Schedule out
podcasts, collabos.
- Oh I know what else.
I've got another always on
commercial for
Instagram stories.
This one I actually
think could be the best.
Got a business question?
Ask GaryVee search engine.
That fucking thing
when people really realize,
people don't know.
People don't realize it.
It's real good.
What's the ROI of us jumping in?
Would that three be nine if
we all stop and do our thing.
- So the interesting
thing is--
- Love Facebook.
- Facebook algorithm is like
the purest form of capitalism.
- Fucking love them.
- Everybody this is
Gary Vay-ner-chuk and this is
episode 238 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
It's windy as hell in New York.
I am filming "Planet of the
Apps" here in New York City so
that's been fun all day and we
found a quick 15 minute window
and I decided to bang
out a call-in show.
So we're gonna
get right into it.
What are you scared of?
Talk to me, help me.
I'm not, this is why I'm
doing the call-in show.
- [Nate] Yeah.
- Because the old show
I would have done your tweet,
I would have answered it.
I would have felt great and then
you wouldn't have done it and
I can feel like there almost got
you there but I'm telling you
right now I don't think you
would do and if you're gonna do
it you're gonna do it
half ass so help me here.
Listen, I'm on your
team so help me here
understand what
you're scared of?
Tell me, tell me the truth.
- [Nate] Yeah, okay so
just because of like
pedigree and how much
education and they've sacrificed
by having a safe job so I got to
do what I want and I
don't want to disappoint them.
- Nate, Nate, Nate,
Nate, let me help you.
- [Nate] Yeah.
- Disappoint for 18 months and
then make them feel good again.
- [Nate] Okay.
- I mean just tell them,
listen, I love you for that.
It means you're appreciative
and love your parents.
Tell them the truth.
Start with that.
I don't want to.
Either your parents love you and
will respond to you or they love
you but they're so deep into
structure and it's been their
whole religion their whole
life that they're incapable even
though they love
you to break through and
see it a different way.
The problem is it's your fucking
life and it's gonna end up one
way or the other.
("Cookie Crumbles"
by D Press)
Hey.
Next.
We could win here is if we could
do a little bit more insights
digging in to the heavy users
or the customers of this product
and segment them from a
psychographic standpoint or from
a demographic standpoint.
This is exactly where we can
tell our story which is however
you guys creatively
interpret the right one to two,
three minute video, we're gonna
compete against one video that's
30 seconds that
tries to tell a story,
I want to walk in with a
strategy that has three videos.
You know, obviously I want to be
empathetic if you have to come
up with six different
commercials for her to munch on
that you know
you're not gonna be,
you're gonna not be
able to storyboard in every.
Like, you get as
far as you can but
minimally six manifesto, right?
Like German woman with two kids
walks into shopping center and
then flash dancing happens and
every baby on Earth is cured.
- Yep, I get it.
Cool.
- [Gary] I don't feel confident
that I can make a
30 second commercial.
- Yeah, I mean, 100%.
- That's it.
- [Marcus] Yeah, yeah. Okay.
- 'Cause I don't
think anybody is.
- [Marcus] Yeah.
- That's the part
I don't think like,
that's my reality.
Like I can't get my juices going
because I don't know
what that commercial is.
It's so hard.
- [Marcus] Yeah.
- I think more videos are over
indexing on social media and not
brand just in general than any
commercials and I think you do
that behavior
you've created your upside.
Marcus is one of the
smartest guys that works here.
That's why he's
in Office of the CEO.
He's very close
to my point of view.
He also pushes back extremely
well and just any time I can
have with them to see if we're
crossing our t and i together.
He's in the trenches.
He's always had a
good cadence of accepting,
forming, pushing back, informing
and so those you know that seven
minutes is what most people
spend an hour and half on going
through deck and
that's how we do it here.
I don't know I have
a fairly big update on.
Can somebody get me, I need the
details on the Snapchat update.
(group laughter)
What the hell am I doin'?
It's really nice.
- [DRock] Yeah, sure.
- [Eliot] Can you
make one vertical also?
- That was pretty fucking quick.
That was, you are quick.
You're quick on the
court and that was quick.
Dunk doesn't know
how to take compliments.
I've noticed
that when I razz him.
- [Eliot] It was
a weird compliment.
- That was a quick move.
And snap and that was fast.
- [Eliot] You're strong.
- I know I'm strong.
I'm real strong by the way.
- So I want to continue crushing
YouTube from there I have this
whole other world that's just
like filling with
opportunity right now.
Alex has been
talking to my main guy.
I built out a team so I have an
Alex now who's like keeping my
world in order
which is incredible.
Quality of life
has gone up 1,000,000%.
And I hit Forbes
30 under 30. Yeah, dog.
But all these big things are
lining up to make me high on
demand my social clout
and perception is like
clear up here right now.
And I've got like
a medium following.
I'm nothing compared to
Viners and whatever else.
But I have a medium good
following and tons of social
perception and clout right now.
- I'm so over on
brand compared to following.
- Yeah, exactly.
That's where I'm at and
that's the direction I want to
keep going.
- Of course.
- I want to be making funny
videos for the rest of my life
so I'm gonna keep doing Snapchat
I do like one every other day.
Do a daily YouTube video.
I started a
side YouTube channel.
I have a guy that runs and
edits my YouTube like DRock.
- And I think everybody else is
using talent as a North Star.
- Yeah.
- And you're making a very smart
decision because there's a big
difference about the wealth
I'm creating versus what other
people are doing?
- Exactly.
- So now, let me give you a
really good piece of advice.
- Go.
- Tomorrow,--
- Yeah?
- get your shit
together on Instagram.
- (laughs) 'Kay.
- Here's why.
- Yeah?
- I just believe in it the most
from attention standpoint and
I know that you in four hours
can fucking figure out all the
right things to make
it way, way, way bigger.
- This guy, GaryVee.
- My man.
- Awkward high five there it is.
- I love it.
- So Gary's the
reason I first started
my very first
business which worked.
Thank you and the reason I
continue to crush it so Gary all
my fans these guys right here.
- Yes.
- They're huge into
chasing their passions.
Lot of them are business
people, finishing college,
whatever else, got
any advice for 'em?
- Look, I mean first of all if
you're following this phenomenal
man you have figured
out a ton of stuff but
I'll give you a couple things.
I really believe in patience.
So many of you are youngsters
and I have thousands of
youngsters hit me
up every day like,
"How do I get this?
How do I get this?"
Patience.
Shaun, you've put in so much
work for such a long time now.
- It's true.
- And so, if you
want great things,
all great things take time.
And so, one of the reasons
I started DailyVee was to show
people it's fucking work.
- Yeah.
- I don't know if
we're allowed to curse.
Beep if it is.
- Bleep it out, it'll be funny.
But like, it's work my friends.
Patience and work and then
driving from that passion spot,
you can win this game.
- [Alyssa] Hey.
- [Gary] Hi.
It's great to
officially meet you.
That was fun.
Thanks for doing that.
- Thank you so
much for having me.
- Nice to meet you, man.
- [Gary] How are you?
Real pleasure, sit, sit, sit.
Do what you're doing but if
you remember anything from this
meeting it's
think about three, five,
seven and ten year terms.
- [Alyssa] Mhmmm.
- [Meir] For sure.
- And so, build your Snapchat
'cause right now everybody's
like Snapchat's dead.
What if they make a feature
tomorrow that's not dead.
- You know what I mean?
Build your,
where's your Facebook at?
- [Meir] Shit.
- Shit. Exactly.
- [Alyssa] Yeah, it is shit.
- And it's more
important than any of them.
It's the only one that's
guaranteed to be around.
So like, do you have a blog?
What's, do you have
an email newsletter?
- [Meir] Yeah, we have email.
- [Alyssa] I have
a ton of email.
- Notice how weird I am, right?
Like I'm sitting
at the top, right?
- [Alyssa] Yeah.
- Yet, I don't have
anywhere close to the
biggest numbers on anything.
- [Alyssa] Right.
- But it's the collective right.
- [Meir] For sure.
- That helps me win and
not the, not being good,
it's the collective proper.
- [Alyssa] Mhmmm.
- It's actually
having a business.
It's actually, like, I don't
know have the most followers but
I also get paid
$125,000 to give a speech.
- [Alyssa and Meir] Right.
- And that's by
being great at everything.
- [Meir] Ultimately,
that's what it comes down to.
- What if Instagram fucks up?
- [Alyssa] Yeah.
- [Gary] All the other stuff.
Do not be at the
mercy of a platform.
- 100%.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- Yeah.
- Awesome.
Great to see you guys.
- Thank you, yeah.
- Yeah.
I don't want it to be
like romance and I have every,
by the way, it's 100% of
my day is based on romance.
So I'm never mad
when romance hits my face.
It's all I fucking
have in front of my face.
I just want to set that tone
of like and then very honestly,
you know with my new
found partnership with Ryan who
I think is great at selling
too, I'm like, fuck this.
("Two" by D Press)
Night.
Goodnight.
It is my full belief that
every product will be smart
eventually, not just our phones
and I believe that even more
importantly as I
think about where AI,
AR, smartification
of our society goes,
everything that brings value to
consumers is interesting to me
not just the current
thing like social media.
So I'm always gonna bet on where
the attention of
the world is going.
Where speed can be picked
up and I definitely believe that
smart products were
one of those places.
So VaynerMedia is one of the
early preferred partners of
Amazon's Alexa skills platform.
This is a game
changer in a lot of ways.
A lot of people may not think
this is a big deal but in four
or five years they will.
You know, I think in 2009, '10
people didn't realize how big of
a deal being an early partner on
the Facebook platform was and so
I'm very proud of our company
and very proud of Patrick who
runs our Vayner Smart
very lean team
of one, two, three.
Incredibly proud of him and
super excited for our brands to
get the benefit of Amazon skills
that I think can absolutely be
disproprionate if there's a
first mover advantage and you
win a skill that people really
enjoy and have hundreds of
thousands of people learn how to
do push-ups or eat this specific
dish or learn how to drink wine
or whatever it may be I think
there's gonna be an enormous
opportunity and I'm excited
about honing my skills deeper in
the Alexa skills world and
voice activation and
things of that nature and
I'm really excited about it.
- Yo. What's up, dude?
How you doing?
- What's up, dude?
I love you.
- [Kevin] Good to see ya.
- So fun, man.
- [Kevin] I love those things.
- Oh my God, I fucking love 'em.
Great to see you man, I've
been so looking forward to this.
It was the first
conference I ever went to.
I was so pumped,
I come up to him,
he's in the corner a bunch of
people are in front of him and
I'm like, "Hey Kevin.
"Yeah, I do this wine thing and
"my show once was on
the first page of Digg."
- [Kevin] Why do you
have your badge on right now?
- [Alex] You pimping, you just
pimping or you cold chilling?
- Don't make me kill you.
- Long time, man.
- Yeah, too long.
- We're like wearing
the same clothes and shit.
- We're just like (laughs).
- Look at you got the little
button like I do too.
- We're like
(laughs), this is perfect.
You got a nice
new fresh haircut.
- Yeah. Of course.
- It's good, man.
Are we ready to sit down?
Right?
- [Alyssa] Yeah.